I did
medicine because I thought that was the
best profession
in the world. That's why I chose to be a
doctor. When I found a better profession
after I met Sheikh Deedat, I changed my
profession. I changed from a doctor of a
body to a doctor of a soul. But my son,
if he says I want to become a da'ee
like my father, therefore I'll do MBBS,
then I'll say, "Son, you're wasting your
time."
Neither send my son to become a doctor,
neither does he want to become a doctor.
I did that. It was the best for me.
Allah made it possible. Alhamdulillah.
But why do medicine?
No, because when you give lecture on
Islam and science, people are impressed.
I tell them that what I speak, you don't
have to waste 5 and 1/2 years. I'll
teach you in 5 months.
And what I speak, what I tell in my
lectures, is not what I learned when I
was in the medical college. That is
superficial. Now I do my research, but
because I have a doctor's label,
they think
I learned in medical college.
Yes, maybe a little bit.
When I speak to a person who's MD or a
DM,
my MBBS knowledge cannot be a match for
a DM. What I do, I do my research.
Even you can do being a non-medical
person. So, the best advice is
join an institute which will help excel
in that field of knowledge, whatever you
want to do, or join an organization.
Practically start. Don't waste your
time.
Is it clear?
Point number 14.
Da'wah means to invite
or call people
to Islam.
Though one of its main parts is calling
people verbally to Islam
at an individual level,
at a group level, or at a public level.
This is not the only act of da'wah.
Though it's one of the most important
acts, calling people verbally,
it's not the only act.
Da'wah also includes calling people by
deeds
and by actions,
including display of noble character,
kindness, etc. Though we will not be
specializing
on da'wah by actions and deeds,
inshallah, there'll be a session
dealing with it titled
the characteristics of a da'ee.
In the objectives, I'm telling you in
detail,
so that you're mentally prepared for the
next 32 days.
If you have thought of something, I'm
clarifying. This is a technique-based
program, not a knowledge-based program.
Da'wah is a variety of types. Mainly
it's calling. We'll be concentrating on
the verbal. There's da'wah by deeds,
da'wah by actions, da'wah by character.
We may just scratch the surface.
That requires another specialty.
Another few days.
But the main da'wah,
da'wah by calling.
All the prophets called.
Action was there. Deed was there. Very
important. Should be there.
But all of them called verbally
also,
besides actions. So, we'll be having a
small session
talking about the basics of the
characteristics of a da'ee, inshallah.
Point number 15.
Islam believes in excellence and
quality.
Even if it is a small task, it should be
done in an excellent manner.
Excellent quality is more important than
quantity.
Quality
is more important than quantity.
But if you can have both, quality and
quantity,
in Hindi we say sone pe suhaga, that
means it is alhamdulillah.
Super excellent.
Quality is more important than quantity,
but if you can have quality and
quantity,
alhamdulillah summa alhamdulillah.
Point number 16.
The international da'wah training
program will, inshallah, be unique and
will lay more emphasis on practical
da'wah.
It will incorporate techniques and
strategies
along with basic knowledge of Islam and
other religions for the effectiveness of
da'wah.
Point number 17.
This 45-day course will include 33 days
training in a comprehensive course
combining the first, second, and third
phase of da'wah training, each
consisting of 11 to 15 days if done
separately.
This is just for your understanding
that the first da'wah training program I
did in my life,
that is
in the mid-90s or
'97, '98, was a one-day training
program.
I'm trying to cover something of the
introduction also in the objectives.
And
then we had the first phase.
We made a proper format.
It was for 15 days.
In the first phase,
I dealt with
techniques of Islamic talks,
structure and content of Islamic talks,
replying to most common questions asked
by non-Muslims, da'wah to Christians,
Hindus, Buddhists, and followers of
other faiths and atheists.
This was mainly the first phase, talking
about techniques
of public speaking,
the structure and content, basic
knowledge of Islam, basic knowledge of
Christianity, Hinduism, Buddhism, other
religion, atheism. The first phase.
The second phase dealt with techniques
of handling question and answer session.
See, normally,
most of the da'ees
or most of the religious speakers, when
they speak, they don't have a question
and answer session. It was Sheikh
Deedat, alhamdulillah, who started this
trend, and now it is continuing.
You give a talk, and you sit. Now, talk
is a monologue.
You really come to know the depth of the
speaker in the question and answer
session.
Talk anyone can memorize and vomit.
The real test
is the question and answer session.
Therefore, in the first phase, we don't
deal much with that. We just show the
structure of the question and answer
session. But the techniques of handling
question and answer session
and debating skills is dealt in the
second phase. Techniques of handling
question and answer session, common
questions asked by non-Muslims, and
debating skills.
So, the first phase,
it's dealing with techniques of public
speaking, common questions, basic
knowledge of Islam and other religions.
Second phase, techniques of handling
question and answer session, more
knowledge
of other religions, and debating skills.
The last international da'wah training
program I had about 16 and 1/2 years
back
was a 25-day training program.
The second phase constitutes about 13,
14 days. When we combine both, the
revision is not there.
So, it is a 25-day training program.
25 working days spread over about
12 to 30, 32 days.
This time, we're including the third
phase.
There are many things in my mind,
and the total
to reach,
if time permits,
minimum 10 phases.
Minimum
10 phases.
So, you multiply that by 11, 12, you can
understand the number of days that it
requires. The third phase includes
specializing of da'wah through satellite
media,
through social media, and setting up
da'wah organization.
So, these features would be added. I
haven't added in the end. I've
interspersed it.
So, the first will be done on the
seventh day, then you have the list of
things that will be done.
In the morning when you read
the theme of the day for all the 33
days, it included
da'wah through satellite media, da'wah
through social media,
setting up a da'wah organization.
So, inshallah, we'll be covering these
points.
The third phase has been spread over the
complete training program.
So, this phase
has been newly
added.
Time may not permit me
to give you notes
for this
new
portion I've added.
It'll be more
of an extempore speech,
more of my experience. So, during these
days,
even the second phase doesn't have much
of notes. It's a practical
training. The first phase has notes.
Though it's not a knowledge-based
program, the notes are few hundred
pages. I don't know, 500
to 1,000 pages it is.
It's not knowledge-based, but yet
it is several hundred pages.
The second phase has very few notes.
It's mainly technique-based and
practical. The third phase, there will
be speeches which you'll find
in my lectures.
But for you, it will mainly be
interaction.
And if you want questions regarding the
specialization, we'll deal with that.
And then third phase, as I said, doesn't
come in the ending.
It's interspersed between the first and
the second phase.
Point number 21.
This is a practical-oriented
public speaking international da'wah
training program
to give to the participants
the experience of professional public
speaking.
Each day of the training, as I mentioned
to you,
would be approximately for 8 to 9 hours.
Though it's 8 hours mentioned in the
day,
but
counting the extension done on some of
the days, on average, it's 8 to 9 hours.
Approximate
50%
of the time
of
these 33 days,
I'll be speaking from the stage.
And that's more in the first phase. More
than 50% I'll be speaking. Less than 5%
would be taken by the other faculty.
Whether Kaleem is there, whether Arthur
is there, whether Naushad Nurani is
there, all these other faculty put
together would constitute
less than 5%.
And the balance 45% you will be
speaking.
Most of the time from the stage,
sometimes even from the floor.
And while you are speaking from the
stage
or from the floor
less than 10%
it would be supervised by the other
faculty. More than 35% I'll be
supervising it.
That means
more than 80% what you will be speaking.
35%
or 45%
is approximately 80% or 45%.
So approximately 45% you will be
speaking in all these days.
From it
more than 80%
I'll be supervising it and less than 20%
would be supervised by the other
faculty.
This is just a bird's-eye view for you.
Are there any questions?
As far as
the last few points are concerned, we
have reached the point number 21. Any
clarification?
Yes, madam.
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykumu salam. On
the issue of we participating on public
speaking
are we going to be given
topic or is just
we are going to be appointed for
impromptu question or something?
Brother, that's the question that will
we be giving topic to speak or it will
be impromptu? It will be both.
When the time comes you will be told
about it, inshallah.